It sounds logical that happy people don't go to war, but we don't know that
McDonald's makes people happy, for one thing, and even if it does, many other
factors could make people unhappy again. For this one, I'm thinking that
countries that have McDonald's tend to be more economically developed. And
therefore have more money, so it's implausible they wouldn't be able to afford
to go to war. That's my own hunch, but I'm pretty sure this is implausible. For
this one, we don't know anything about how many people eat at McDonalds and how
often, and we don't even know for sure if eating McDonalds would make people too
unhealthy to engage in a war. This one seems to be the most plausible option.
Countries with McDonald's are more open to globalization, and less inclined to
go to war. But I have to admit, that would be pretty awesome if we could obtain
world peace just by building a McDonald's in every country. If that were true, I
would definitely advocate for that.